as you can see the health secretary matt
hancock uh joins us once again in the
studio good to see you this morning
minister um thanks for having me
so much to talk about but i think many
people will immediately have focused on
words from the prime minister yesterday
he suggested that it may be that in the
we need to do things in the next few
weeks that
that that may be tougher what would you
mean by that
well we keep these things under constant
review as you know and
and and as we've shown um unfortunately
the number of cases is rising and in
some parts of the country
so for instance some of the tier three
areas
are seeing sharp rises in cases and
each week we look at all of the areas of
the country
to check that they're in the right
position in terms of the tears
but it is a very difficult situation
in terms of the growth of the of the
virus
but then we also have this very good
news this morning it's a real
pivotal moment with the the arrival
actually in the hospitals of
uh of the uk of the oxford vaccine but
just in terms of
of the national lockdown as proposed as
you know by the leader of the opposition
that isn't within the government
thinking then right now is it well we
don't rule anything out
and we've shown repeatedly that we will
look at the
public health advice and we'll take the
public health advice
in terms of what's needed to control the
spread of the disease
now this new variant is much easier to
catch it's much more transmissible
and we're now seeing the effect of that
in lots of different parts of the
country unfortunately and it means that
you know whereas the old tier 3 was able
to
contain the old variant that is proving
increasingly difficult in
in all parts of the country where there
was the evidence that tier four
is able to contain it i mean if you just
look at london been in tier four you
know since
you know the beginning middle of
december let's say i mean if you look at
the results in the week up to the 29th
of december which
clearly don't include any transmission
that took place over the christmas
bubble
over the christmas window you know we
are seeing cases accelerating out of
control here
i mean do you still think tier 4 works
well it's down to people's behavior
frankly
um there's what matters is yes of course
the rules that we put in place
but it's also about how people act and
frankly what i'd say is this
it is critical that everybody in the
country
does all that they can to reduce the
spread
of the virus it's of course it's on it's
own clearly they're not doing so
if that if there are either two things
are happening here either
the transmissibility of the virus is
such that tier four in and of itself
isn't enough
to control the spread of the virus to
even bring it down to slow its spread
or as you've just suggested it's our
fault
people aren't adhering to the rules so
what do we do then
so so i'd put it slightly differently
okay this is a massive
national effort right it's a massive
team effort across the country as a
whole
we have our part to play of course we do
but whether it's on
keeping the virus under control or
whether it's on
the rollout of the of the vaccine and
all of the work alongside that
this is a massive national effort and
it's on all of us
so this isn't about blame it's about how
we collectively as
a society keep this under control for
the next
couple of months you know these weeks of
winter that are going to be very
difficult
until the vaccines can make us safe and
on that we obviously have the
the the very positive news this morning
of the oxford vaccine starting to be
rolled out it's
uh you know that's a triumph of british
science that we've managed to get to
where we
we are but this new variant does make it
so much
harder to control the vaccine in the
meantime but just just in terms of the
vaccine look every day on this program
we repeat
the statistics about the number of new
cases we repeat the numbers of people
who have died
with quote a positive covert 19 19 tests
we'd quite like to provide some accurate
information daily information
on how many people are getting
vaccinated because frankly that seems
like one of the few good news stories
around at the moment
could we get that information from your
department on a daily basis
well we publish it weekly at the moment
and yeah we've been
we've been working so hard with the nhs
doing such a brilliant job to get this
up and running at pace we've obviously
delivered more than a million
vaccines into arms already that's more
than the rest of europe
put together i'm really proud of how the
nhs have really risen to this challenge
from today we accelerate that path
we've got from today 700 vaccination
sites open across the uk
by the end of the week it's due to be
over a thousand
uh so the there's plenty of statistics i
can keep going
i'm really really pleased and and the
whole of the nhs is is leading into this
incredibly important national effort
and it it's only because right at the
start
we saw that the vaccine was the only way
out
long term we backed the the scientists
at
oxford and we teamed them up with
astrazeneca who themselves are doing a
great job and now we have this big
british success story
starting today but we will see in a few
we'll have to leave a few weeks until we
get to the point of saying that we've
got the vaccination program going quite
as quite as you'd like and
you know daily information would help us
in assessing that but just in terms of
the vaccines a huge amount of concern
about a change to the protocol the
distance between the first
and the second doses explain this one to
us because
there are plenty of people who suggest
well i took that first vaccine
on the promise that i would get the
second one as scheduled
why is that not happening and how
concerned should people be it's
it's a really positive change for the
country as a whole and indeed for the
world that
you can wait until 12 weeks to get the
second dose
and the signs with the astrazeneca
vaccine are that you get a better
uh protection if you wait that bit
longer can you give us a percentage
terms of uh
well the scientist is five to eighteen
the scientists have settled
that out and also these percentages
you've got to be careful because that's
percentage of what right because
actually what we're looking for
is not only obviously people not
catching the disease
is the best protection but also the
vaccine even if you
do it protects you from serious disease
these vaccines are
effective and they're safe and the
critical thing
is if since we have these doses
available
do you use any two doses to dose
two people to give them that protection
which starts after the first dose
or do you give one person two doses
which actually leaves somebody else
without that protection
at all so imagine if you've got two
grandparents and you've got two doses of
vaccine right you want to give one each
because then they both get the uh get
the get that protection yeah and indeed
chief medical officers of wales scotland
northern ireland england all and party
on this in terms of schools however we
have a situation this morning
in which there will be primary schools
up and down the country contrary to
government advice
not opening what is the government going
to do about that
well i think on schools it's incredibly
challenging because obviously keeping
kids in education is so important
as the prime minister said yesterday we
will follow and
the public health advice on schools
in the areas of the country like london
that you mentioned earlier
where the diseases has spread the
the broadest and the pressures on the
nhs are the greatest
there we are not opening uh primary
schools
uh but there are there are pressures
across the country
um and that's why in the parts of the of
the country
that we have set out yeah we have a
situation at the moment in which there
are you know
local authorities in direct
contravention of the advice coming from
the department for education
telling their head teachers this morning
if you want to close the schools that's
absolutely fine with us it's a rather
chaotic situation
we have the neu nes uwt all of them
saying
schools are not safe not just for pupils
to go back into
but for teachers if frontline
professionals in the education system
are telling you that they are not
confident going back into school on what
basis
do you say that schools are safe well on
the basis of the public health advice
which i think is incredibly important as
the
uh uh as the core question
that we're facing is how do we deal with
this pandemic
and the public health advice is a is
absolutely critical to that
so that's what people should be
listening to the advice of the advice is
that the data suggests that young people
are
less affected by the most severe effects
of of the coronavirus
that doesn't mean it's safe for teachers
yes there's also
it's also clear that the proportion of
teachers who
catch coronavirus is no higher than the
rest of the population
so you know there is clear public health
advice
behind the position that we take and
that's that is what people should follow
because of course
education is very important as well
especially for people's long-term health
so you've got people watching this this
morning who know that in their area
where primary schools are opening
this morning there is a similar
infection rate to that in tier four
london
well you've got to follow the public
health advice and that's what we
are doing in this air in this space
whilst also
of course part of that public health uh
balance is the fact that education is
incredibly important to the
long-term prospects again the teachers
there are teachers up and down the
country who don't believe you
there are head teachers up and down the
country who are in direct disagreement
with
the secretary of state for education
this morning
it's pretty chaotic at the very least
well i i think
that that's uh a challenge that we have
across the whole of this response this
pandemic is you do
sometimes have to move fast and we have
moved fast for instance
in in saying that london schools
shouldn't
come back based on that public health
advice
and i know sometimes we get criticized
for
for moving fast and changing things but
that's what you have to do in a panel
but can't we act in anticipation we know
that the data doesn't accurately reflect
the transmission that will have taken
place in domestic environments
over the christmas period we know that
the case numbers are only going to get
worse
we know that the rate of transmission is
only going to get worse
why are we waiting to go for a full
national lockdown
well we've acted very rapidly to put
areas into tier four
and obviously we keep that data under
review all the time
and so that's that's a critical part of
the the job that we've got
and we then act very fast so for
instance you know when we saw the new
variant
arrive in uh and we got the advice
on it's the fact that it's more
contagious it transmits so much more
quickly
we then acted within 24 hours
and to put that into to put in further
measures that needed to be taken so
absolutely we're prepared to act when
it's necessary
following and listening to that public
health advice mr hancock good to see you
a busy few weeks ahead we'll let you go
on with it thanks for joining us thank
you very much